[Musique]
bonjour sa fait mal soyez les bienvenus
vous regardez quelle première le
magazine consacré au tour de la
martinique des yoles rondes tous les
jours avec william nous sommes au coeur
de l'ambiance est bien évidemment au
coeur de la course la troisième étape
est parti ce matin du prêcheur pour une
arrivée à chelles cher au programme de
votre magazine de l'émotion les analyses
de nos spécialistes et les résultats
bien sûr la fête se déroule sur terre
mais également en mer alors aujourd'hui
avec william on a décidé de partir en
bateau pour être le plus proche des
conseillers mais tout de suite c'est le
résumé de l'étape ses coûts cela des
avaries des duel à couteaux tirés de
l'ambiance à revendre sur terre comme
sur l'eau
bayonne qui passe au plus près du public
et des courses kaki au chaud dans tous
les sens du terme
une troisième étape entre le prêcheur et
chercher à première bouée à laisser à
tribord au large de belle fontaine puis
une deuxième à virer à schoelcher avant
de rallier la ligne d'arrivée
bon départ pour ce même se marrer petit
navire ufr chanflor les appétits
l'appaloosa l'ufr chamfort et rosette
orange première et deuxième au
classement général se marque avec dix
mètres carrés de plus aco a prévu
d'attaquer aujourd'hui les embarcations
longe la côte pour quitter le prêcheur
et déjà l'écart se creuse entre les
quatre viols de tête même se marrer que
petit navire mutuelle mare gaillard et
ufr et leurs poursuivantes zapetti
l'appaloosa rosette orange et gf1
caraïbes les équipages effectué de
nombreux virements de bord il faut
manoeuvrer pour arriver au carbet sur
sept et des âmes les coursiers profitent
des bonnes conditions de navigation ils
savent que ça ne va pas durer
cette fausse rafale est là pour le leur
rappeler
rosette orange penche dangereusement
laguiole coulera quelques instants plus
tard
en tête tout va bien pour ce même
l'équipage est décidé à poursuivre sa
remontée au classement général de son
côté se marrer que se verrait bien
renouer avec la réussite de la première
étape à condition de ne pas se laisser
surprendre
la course est lancée les loups des
caraïbes sont de sortie lauren sahara au
large ce même près de la côte
ufr en embuscade ce n'est pas bon signe
steve jacassant rendra vite compte félix
mérine n'en fait qu'une bouchée s'engage
alors une interminable duel avec les
hommes de gianni rémy al avantage d
robertin qui file en tête tandis que
brasserie lorraine sa rare est
encalminée la conditions de navigation
sont changeantes il faut trouver le bon
réglage et tenter de garder son sang
froid du sang froid les hommes de
rosette en auront besoin
après avoir remonté les voilà qui entame
une remontée qui semble déjà perdu
d'avancé
[Musique]
très loin devant à la bo de
bellefontaine ufr est en tête devant
brasserie lorraine sa race même esso
marek
madiagne et rémy n'a pas dit son dernier
mot les coursiers jettent toutes leurs
forces dans la bataille et cela va payer
félix mérine aura beau embarqué du poids
à bord maîtriser les rafales contenir
les assauts de son adversaire
les marinois vont s'offrir une première
victoire
[Musique]
et tandis que ce même cool elle devant
la révélation du tour 2010 8 s'octroie
la dernière place du podium
[Musique]
première victoire d'étape pour brasserie
lorraine sarah énergies nouvelles fin de
la suprématie pour ufr chanflor deuxième
à 2 minutes et 8 secondes avec devon
troisième réussi une excellente
performance à 10 minutes et 42 secondes
brico batn au titan est quatrième ce
même 5e impressionnante remontée de
rosette orange 6e à 22 minutes du leader
en deuxième partie de tableau on
retrouve cette idée m
onzième disque un espace santé optical
center 12e
tania chaussures 16e a été tracté
jusqu'à la ligne d'arrivée au classement
général ufr chamfort conserve donc son
maillot rouge après une belle
démonstration de force aujourd'hui
brasserie lorraine sarah énergies
nouvelles est deuxième à 10 minutes et
14 secondes
en revanche ça se gâte pour rose et
orange à trente deux minutes ils devront
confirme sa bonne forme sur le tour et
sa progression laguiole est quatrième à
quarante et une minutes et 35 secondes
pour les franciscains 2 appétit
l'appaloosa en revanche c'est une année
sans les frères maçons 9e
[Musique]
en deuxième partie de tableau on
retrouve 4 10 40 est passante et optical
center 11e mutuelle mare gaillard royal
fruit de martinique adeptes et tania
chaussures sm msr termine le classement
[Musique]
yahia
c'est vrai
[Musique]
le dosage
[Applaudissements]
y aller vite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'imagine que vous êtes contente
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il
[Musique]
carnaval femmes et légendes france et
surtout le tour des yoles
alors aujourd'hui c'est prince billy
bragg a remporté cette troisième étape
c'est la folie
mais la folie chez brasserie est chez
lui à faire parce que fr est leader au
général
bravo à tous alors il ya qu'en pensent
les et qui s'est même donnant la parole
aux patrons ces paroles may be dragons
qui commence et on sait qu'un ange ou
disparaît course il fallait qu'on est
quand même avec l'arrêt de tête comme on
dit aujourd'hui en profitant d'un
objectif de revendeurs comme on le vend
la bccla lait qu'ils allaient nous
dépasser d'accord comme on dit on l'a vu
on est resté au contact avec eux on a
aussi battu et puis on savait que a
gâché chocs et aux enfants ont signé
voilà j'avais les sites médias parce que
on a été vraiment costaud je t'ai l'état
parce que c'était pas évident il y avait
beaucoup beaucoup plus de votes qui
était prévu on a plutôt eu sept voiles
tant mieux je dis chapeau à mon équipage
pas si on a on a bien envie d'y en avoir
mis la vidéo est ici deuxième vrai
combat des brasseries dorénavant compter
dans la voyait très bien
oui madame manon mam est bombardée nous
tant mieux e
ma dette à mort en va
on va donc savoir aguas owen que je me
bats ma compassion général ça va mieux
c'est mieux aux usa ce débat mais savez
vous l avais dit que c'est tout là c'est
l'avocat on court beaucoup ici et on a
le terrain vous bien figurer dans ce
tour c'était quand même dixième
hier vous remonter dans le classement
grâce à cette personne oui et on espère
demain si je veux faire la même chose
parce que c'est petit à petit la tour
n'est pas encore fini c'est comme c'est
maintenant ça commence
l'objectif l'objectif c'est en vison mer
parmi les cinq premiers le 6 ce sera
beau c'est déjà beau le voyou mais bon
je suis quand même satisfait de ma
cinquième place les gars se sont bien
battus et la voie était vraiment
vraiment fois on arrive voilà de bonnes
vibrations lorsque on amène un peu la
course au début on s'était dit qu'on
joue du conte à l'héroïne venus prier
pour battre une étape mais bon on n'a
pas réussi mais aux morts parmi le top
c'est quand même l'objectif qu'on en a
aussi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le rythme des chansons mais papa milieu
d'un petit globe de n 1 allemand
à william présent les nouveaux potes
jawad édition
pour milo
message aux 2000 au avait donné des
cauchemars fait semblant savoir aller on
a été gentil tu me présente
jawad et volets multiples débats
bobby
c'est trop vite
vidic oui c'est normal c'est plutôt le
tour des yoles
[Musique]
je vais faire que ce soit sur les
vacances ils mangent une pipe
vous êtes à combien de vocations
en trois jours
alors oui ce jeu est un artiste
by passel ce n'est pas que c'est
mardi le tour des yoles si ça
le hobby c'est monsieur place avec des
tirs après cette vidéo il ya de la
qualité du quotidien aussi
tu es donc ce qu'on appelle un
influenceur
ça comme ça effectivement d'ailleurs
quelle est la tendance sur ce tour pour
moi ce ne sera pas la question parce que
je suis notre séquence en veille
[Musique]
le loup pantel chaponost sexy mal de
belles sexy choc des sandales il faut
être sans emploi est faite au centre
plutôt louche à fermer des taignons
plusieurs heures mais je vais même si
plusieurs jours parce qu'en garde ça
pour toute la semaine très neuf vrais
fanatiques ont fait pas deux étapes
m'ont fait toute la semaine des maillots
de bain bière nette short hilton veut
décontractée bonne plage voilà c'est
simple
certes maillot chant petit chien soit
sandales sebago calme quoi et j'ai fait
des hongroises est d'aider mes cheveux
bleus et puis c'est tout c'est tout
du look si le sourire parce que ce soit
le sourire la joie de sa faute si ça le
toit donc le sourire en un chapeau
lunettes et le maillot des t-shirts avec
ou lebron est le sponsor bois sidler à
la et la cassette supporter
notre sponsor est toujours là soutient
mais bon c'est pour montrer aussi un peu
la différence par rapport à ma bosse
pour unis que nous avons ici en
martinique donc passé aussi que laguiole
c'est quelque chose d'unique au monde
donc un moment faut mettre aussi de
l'originalité conçu pour tenir ce que
j'ai fait c'est une carte de l'afrique
avec le couleurs rouge vert noir donc du
panafricanisme vente autres aussi qui
connaissent un peu la définition des
sept couleurs
[Musique]
franchement j'ai pas d'éléments
incontournables juste je suis moi même
j'ai mon look propres à ma personnalité
tout simplement goûter bien
bon le soleil toi mais je sois ici comme
sous ellaone a touché un nouveau ep qui
est la mauvaise mais malheureusement
quand je suis allé chez rosette pour les
choses dit il n'ya pas ma politique une
petite mais attention j'ai le chanteur
aux est aussi chaque jour via un géant
comme un différentiel de confiner à moi
qui a fait le sac pour moi comme ça va
j'ai trouvé cela fait de ce pack pour
moi de moi seul qui a le sac de rosette
retrouver toutefois il faut que ce soit
une lip la saône à mâcon nous voilà
[Musique]
les
hier la très belle régate du prêcheur à
laquelle nous avons assisté a été
surprenant et très éprouvante pour tout
les coursiers et notamment pour au royal
ils sont arrivés derniers en plus de
deux heures ils ont coulé deux fois ils
sont allés au bout d'eux mêmes et nos
caméras embarquées étaient à bord de
l'équipage c'est notre séquence en trio
là ce matin on a fait un bon débat parce
qu'on avait choisi une bonne voie et on
a choisi une 42 mètres carrés parce que
c'est vrai qu' on n'est pas très
aguerris au niveau des auteurs et je
pensais qu'à ça nous aurait permis de
bien naviguer qu'on est passé à 5 heures
ce matin on a vu qu'il y avait beaucoup
de vent vient même vers l'île et la
paire eur/jpy vous regardez avec le
scooter
il y avait même trop de vent
l'initiative aujourd'hui c'était de
mettre une petite voile ou entrer abobo
on a prêté ses pierres et c'est là qu'on
a retrouvé la cata
[Musique]
non pour les deux fois et c'est toujours
mon dos vigilance m haies en courant
pas pendant qu'ils allaient les gosses
rafale mais toujours dans les accalmies
et ça c'est la fatigue
[Musique]
le parcours d'aujourd'hui n'était pas
très difficile mais c'était long la
preuve que la fédération a pris
l'initiative de rap aussi et ceux qui
reviendront plus long le projet le
manque de vent
dès ce soir dans le débrief on va
essayer de motiver nos gars parce que là
ils sont vraiment découragé on va
travailler surtout le mental et courage
demain on n'est qu'au deuxième étape
faut pas se décourager
[Musique]
à part des autres catamarans nous avons
rencontré trois membres de l'association
swagg man à une association à caractère
social et festivités tuer la présidente
est que tout est présenté alors ne se
resserre donc de carnaval de ports de
france hugues atchy l'ermitage nous
avons sinon ça fait quatre ans que nous
participons au tour des yoles avec
curistes et en dehors de ça mais en
fraude de faire la fête
et sociale où nous fêtons nos jeunes à
s'insérer pour lui de rester dans
l'armée alors vous êtes des habitués du
tour
mais est ce que vous savez tout sur la
yole et notamment la voile par exemple
année ça tombe bien parce que c'est le
moment de notre rubrique technique yoles
et on va tout savoir sur cet élément
essentiel la voile
[Musique]
la voile est en polyester sa surface pas
de 32 à 86 m² elle pèse 2,7 à 20 kg
à l'origine la voile était en coton elle
était le monde surtout quand elles
étaient mouillés le coton tissus souples
était déformé par le vent ce qui
n'assurait pas une propulsion optimale
après une première évolution le coton a
disparu au profit du nylon puis du
polyester qui a tout changé désormais
deux types de polyester sont utilisés le
dacron et le mylar des tissus étanche
rigide et léger les voiles sont
découpées au laser et assemblé avec soin
la voilure a une durée de vie d'environ
trois ans selon la taille
il faut compter de 3 à 6000 euros sa
fonction est de propulser la yole
[Musique]
la voile est le moteur de laguiole elle
sert à faire avancer l'embarcation mais
attention le risque zéro n'existe pas
selon le profil de l'étape et le vent
annoncé le patron de l'équipage choisit
parfois quelques dizaines de minutes du
départ la taille de sa voilure - il ya
devant plus il faut de la surface pour
avancer mais le risque c'est de ne pas
réussir à tenir la voile en cas de
fortes rafales
il faudra des coursiers à seymour et
agile pour faire le contrepoids une
erreur et c'est là varient
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on est bien petit gars sur mon bateau
je savais pas tenir a tôt fait trois ans
qu'on travaille ensemble et il sait pas
tout
le russe tmh
cachin possible
oui un mondial oui
est ce que moi je sais pas où tu vois
j'ai pourtant que ce soit perturbée mais
c'est plutôt par là bas qu'on va aller
et c'est moi capital boxes de reprendre
la barre ça dérange pas
excuse non pardon capitaine je suis ok
tout ça pour vous impressionner non mais
c'est vrai tu avais raison ne peut pas
tout savoir si on donnait la parole à
quelqu'un qui sait tout dans notre
émission quatre premières places à jean
trudeau notre doc terol qui va nous dire
ce qui a fait la différence sur l'eau
aujourd'hui sur ce qui attend les
équipages demain nous qui pensions avoir
des gars tranquille aujourd'hui on parle
de du prêcheur
on va vers saint-pierre peut-être les
bourrasques qui descendent de l'appeler
après petites difficultés prévues à
bellefontaine l'autre petite difficulté
petite accalmie n'est au carbet casse
pilote tout le long on se disait que
rien ne va se passer non ufr chanflor
après débord prend la tête à bellefond
de là aussi on se dit que tout est fini
le leader rassure il va arriver à
chercher à gouverner ni derrière
brasserie lorraine s'étiole va plus vite
de ne plus vite que faire simple on l a
pas sous le vent elle va virer la bouée
la pointe des arrivent en grand
vainqueur à schoelcher traîne dans son
sillage notre petite fiole sans sponsor
à émouvant de ses talents et puis en
deuxième position ufr champion de mais
demain ça sera très compliqué il faut
partir à l'affairé une bouée après coup
et traverser la baie difficulté
peut-être du côté de cap salomon et puis
le rocher du diamant avant d'arriver au
sens dans les choix le voir tactique
demain ce sera très très très difficile
est ce qu'on vient de grand voile pour
traverser la main au portant est ce
qu'on veut une voile qui permet de
remonter au plus près peut-être dans la
passe des faux choix ne vois aller puis
celles qui sont derrière l'établissement
voisin qui a perdu beaucoup beaucoup de
temps aujourd'hui va vouloir se refaire
une santé dans les cinq premiers on a
new york on ne voyait pas du tout avant
qu'on va voir donc les mappings ne sont
pas à la fête
donc demain on ne garde pas le pilote
moi qui avait payé vu que ça se
passerait jeudi mais je crois que ça va
se passer demain
[Musique]
demande qu'est ce qui nous attend une
superbe 4e étape tiga entre chelle cher
et les anses d'arlet une étape très
apprécié par les plaisanciers
c'est vrai parce qu'elle est très belle
mais attention il y aura du danger et
des pièges à éviter pour tous les
coursiers les détails dans cap la 4e
étape
schoelcher ans d'art les étapes de tous
les dangers passer la pointe des
tirez des bons pour aller virer la
marque numéro un qui est placé à pao
cauet dans laxe de l'aéroport voir filer
vers les deux bouts et verte de l'espace
sud côté pointe du bout puis le passage
à côté de lille est haram y ait un peu
après les deux ans ans du four pour
aller vers ce fameux cap salomon avec
ses vents changeants en force et en
direction
puis commencer à broder les voiles pour
remonter pour aller à la marque numéro
deux le rocher du diamant en laissant de
côté toutes ces difficultés que
constitue le monde jacqueline les
petites en cela pas ce défaut pour aller
virer cette man que numéro 2 rocher du
diamant à laisser sur bâbord retourner
voile fils est retombé dans ses
difficultés que constitue la passe
défaut le monde jacqueline en
particulier pour les contourner cette
marque numéro 3 a laissé sur tribaux ou
coupé la ligne d'arrivée entre deux
bouées mouillées devant la plage baudet
ans d'art
[Musique]
et robin a dit aqa première votre rendez
vous quotidien consacré au tour de la
martinique des yoles rondes c'est
terminé pour aujourd'hui la quatrième
étape partira demain 10 6 h el cheikh
pour arriver au sens d'arles et on vous
attend nombreux venez faire la fête avec
nous il y aura de l'ambiance pour revoir
cette émission rendez vous sur le ripper
de france télévisions rendez-vous
également tous les jours à 20h sur
martinique 1ère et pour l'élève tous et
7h35 surprend
[Musique]
12h08